thank you
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
careful boys we are about to talk about
something that needs to be discussed why
the [ __ ] do Asian men think women don't
like them because why because they got
their tiny eyes and their tiny little
dicks all right
one in this room is in relationships
right Multicultural or in the past we've
dated out of just Asian girls or
whatever and then like
and and and you know like some you know
like basically what I realized is
overtime right
um there is a sub set of Asian dudes
sometimes they're very vocal and then
they talk about this [ __ ] all the time
when you're out there when you're when
you're when you're hanging when you're
out there enjoying life
when you're when you're out there
actually dating women having like
romantic experiences and you're having
fun you're too busy dating and enjoying
that to talk about it so then when these
guys talk about it and I'm just like
holy that is not me that is not the
people I know these are my friends right
who the [ __ ] things like this so here's
the question race has who's dating
outside of their ethnicity
uh like Asian as a blanket statement or
like he has a blanket state or you've
have yeah or you've had
don't see a [ __ ] problem here right I
don't see the problem here she's a [ __ ]
well you're actually dating a prisoner
he said he actually did it outside of
his jeans his species
but I do I do I do think that like
there's there's definitely I didn't see
that code a lot when we were growing up
right
um like you would kind of hear this from
like and you always thought they were
just like nerds or like losers or
someone that was like oh life I can't
get no like girls and specifically they
would mention they can't get out
non-asian girls or non-asian girls don't
like us and I'm like wait like
so you can get Asian girls but you can't
get non-asian girls no they can't get
girls in general exactly usually guys
that talk like that can't get girls at
all it's not it's not an ethnicity thing
it's a youth thing all women reject you
you're disgusting
it's not like you're talking about one
significant person oh man I don't know
it's like sometimes it's like it's
always these two pair of brothers that
just
Hey listen listen listen listen I'm a
peaceful guy I'm a very beautiful sounds
like you want more it sounds like you
want some heat but you know by the way
it's not meant to be a flex that you're
dating outside your race it's not meant
to be a place yeah it's meant to be a
fail if you think you can't
exactly exactly not any [ __ ] cooler
yeah it's just that's normal everyone
should be able to do that that the weird
thing is when they when they put other
races on a pedestal yeah like like
they're like oh I got me [ __ ] this
girl or white girl or Latina and it's
like what makes you special it's like
you just found a woman that'll tolerate
you and stick around
and that's it that's exactly feel about
a relationship is is like can they
tolerate your [ __ ] and are you willing
to tolerate their [ __ ] and do you want
to stick around for it right your
culture background religion everything
but then in cells that's never dated
they just see them as a sex object yeah
it's like oh this is the same as people
really yeah literally it's weird yeah I
just don't understand like the
glorification like what what do you do
so you let's say because for example
there's like a big thing within like
Asian guys who look at the Asian guy
with the white girl and they go oh you
got a white girl it's like okay what
they can play more the Asian girls I'll
tell you
they're annoying too sometimes they're
wait dude if they get their Starbucks
order wrong bro man
articulate so they [ __ ] complain like
a [ __ ]
grammatically correcting [ __ ] here's the
reason why I'm mad
what is this it's a bird
[ __ ] white girl dude the way you
speak to me is so toxic there is one
weird thing though that when I I
remember when I first moved to America
from Japan there was maybe for the first
year for some odd reason even if I like
someone outside my race I automatically
didn't even try because I thought they
wouldn't be interested in me until I got
an American girlfriend and it was like
oh but it was just all in my head where
did that do you think that Japanese
stereotype or do you think that is a
Asian guy in America stereotype she
doesn't count he's outside the special
I'm getting turned on listening to him
right now that's like not here you do
have the Exotic accent things yeah I get
that but also too it's like still at the
same point you're like if I I drew a
racist drawing of a Japanese person it's
you right
yes yeah really boom minus the hair but
like other than that like you look
pretty Japanese right so somebody who
has very like ethno very particular you
know like you're dating outside of your
race
this looks like Japanese
[Laughter]
you really think I look stereotypically
Japanese I think you have a very
Japanese face oh right interesting you
are darker than the average yeah he's
great that's Hawaiian to Me Maybe
Japanese on vacation
he's from Hawaii yeah yeah that's some
like Filipino stereotype [ __ ] right if
you're like you're like super dark
skinned you're [ __ ] a field worker
therefore you're probably lower class
you're 15 40s Japanese he's like more
like an 1830s Japanese
he's the future Japanese but that's
interesting when you have that thought
because maybe that's where like some of
these people get that thought from
because my first I guess girlfriend in
second grade like or the crush that we
had it was already interracial So like
um maybe because I grew up in a diverse
City just we just never had like races
or whatever on pedestals or you just saw
everyone with it if everybody was just
poor yeah so that for you
um like what was the thought of uh oh
they wouldn't like me or but I do like
her I think it's a combination of
different things and you know my first
technically girlfriend when I was really
young when I was in England we were like
12 or something she was English so I
shouldn't think that way but I think
this time I spent in Japan
I don't know I think it's just
automatically probably media and stuff
too you just automatically think you're
inferior to in comparison to other race
and I I don't know it took me a good
year to snap out and be you know and
realize you're a superior
inferior yeah and it was it was so
strong that it was fear you know
even if you fancy someone it's not even
an option to
you know say stuff because even if you
fancy you know it's funny because my my
girl is British too so and but when she
she says that her and her friends refer
to me as the American so they don't even
see a Japanese American they just see as
the oh that like the American is more
prominent than the Japanese side whereas
in America they look at me as like oh
it's an Asian guy right right right so
it's it's for the Chinese guy or the
child I brought covet to America you
know what I mean like I think the
annoying part is is like a lot of these
people who want to be in the Forefront
of of like redefining what Asian
masculinity is they are not the
definition of Asian masculine why is it
always that you know what I mean so this
is because you have to understand
something this is the weird part right
so how can you say that you are for
Asian men in their masculinity when you
say the reason why women don't like you
is because you're Asian yeah that's wild
that does not make sense so how is it
that your culture is the thing that's
holding you back when you're trying to
say that you're you're about your
culture typically blame media and white
men for making them look weak or
whatever right but then I'm like but I
see a photo of who these people are and
they look weak yeah also too like you're
just traditionally ugly it's all Races
yeah yeah like if you were a white
person you 'd be ugly and alone exactly
but okay if if it was a handsome dude
saying this it's more convincing because
it's like oh here's a tall handsome
strong looking cool guy that actually
believes this and I'm like let me it's
let me listen to this but if it's a
[ __ ] ugly like unhygienic dweeb
talking about man Asian guys we're not
represented in the right way I'm like
bro cause you don't represent us in the
right way also don't represent us please
we don't need you the greater problem
that is like the root of that is I think
there's a problem with Asian people
where they they fail at something and to
rationalize it in their head they say
it's not meant for Asians yeah I failed
at it Asian people this doesn't happen
for us yeah but it's like dude that's
just you trying to feel better about not
doing something but it's a brush your
teeth penises
yeah yeah try that
but it's also generational it's like our
parents did the same thing our parents
didn't succeed at something and they say
oh that's off limits for you too yeah
it's like well is it because they would
say that type of [ __ ] too like I used to
think the same way that Hawk did when I
was like 12 but like as I got older I
realized like oh that's just some [ __ ] I
thought myself
I didn't make that gang joke kill him
that gang sounds fun let me tell you
something that's a very scary thing it's
like the same effect we were talking
about where you have like the people
that are preaching abstinence at your
school and they're hella ugly yeah yeah
like yeah you wish I don't believe in
sex before sex doesn't believe in you
sex doesn't believe in you and I'll say
that because I was a part of that group
and it was really rough and you know
what I did I brushed my teeth nice right
yeah I got a decent fade
right that's all you need if I started
showering more often
I stopped getting the Eight dollar
Vietnamese haircuts you know what I mean
number one number two that's it I
started doing it can I get a uh can you
like fade the side and then maybe I
don't know do this whatever
it reminds me of those like men's rights
dudes that are like a compensating extra
[ __ ] heart to be macho but it's like
when you look at them you're like ah but
you guys really aren't yeah right and
it's the same thing like when they're
when you're complaining about oh man
they don't think I'm sexy enough because
the media or whatever that's the media
that definition that act alone is unsexy
complaining about how unsexy you are or
like complaining about not being able to
like attract women or whatever just that
just addressing it and doing it and
vocalizing it alone I think is a trait
that repels women to the internet too to
the to the masses to the masses
if you're so passionate about it too why
don't you be the change that you want to
see then oh man in the mirror what would
David Gogan say to those guess what I
guess what I did I married a Korean
woman
I'm married in-house but you be the
champ and you'll be the change I don't
care yeah I'm a Korean supremacist
if you want Korean everything these guys
that obsess about this stuff they're
always obsessing about
um non-asian women because they're
fetishized in like if people think about
how they speak right they're fetishizing
women of different cultures because it's
porn to them they want to [ __ ] all these
different cultures but they're like my
chances are low because they don't like
Asian men it's never spoken in a more
authentic romantic loving sort of way I
want a relationship but I'm like why
would you want to have a relationship
with a racist or an idiot because if
they have these preconceived biases it's
like why would you want an unintelligent
idiot for a date like you want to have a
genuine human being and if you believe
all women are [ __ ] too dumb to make
decisions for themselves and go oh yeah
you might be a real fun guy like let's
[ __ ] chill or whatever over but if
you think all of them believe oh Asian
guys are all ugly or stupid because of
the media then that just says that's
really it really kind of paints a
picture of how you view women yeah you
view them as low IQ creatures that can't
make [ __ ] decisions and it's like
dude so you're not one woman can find
you attractive because they're all
brainwashed by the media have you ever
heard a woman that's not Asian
explicitly say I don't date Asian men
depends who's asking them
but they probably do those questions on
Tick Tock or something
what I've heard though okay they say
they don't but they put us at like
number 12 yeah yeah you see that you see
our credit score [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] wet huh yeah you want
that house yeah what's up it's like
you're running a used audience
where's that loan credit yeah you can't
lease that Maserati yeah what's that
FICO score like hey amen
okay okay
City USA superior man oh my God that's
crazy I never understood about that the
small penis stereotype though oh it's
over here
representative
right but it's hard though right kind of
behind it kind of the expectation is
lowered if you have like average then
it's a bonus it's a bonus boner yeah
you're smart out of all the things we
said today that was the most genius
statement and I've always been so
confused it's like oh that's such a bad
thing when you change it's like no it's
giving you a [ __ ] yeah
bridge is good boner bonus because even
if it is then it's like you don't lose
anything they expected it so it's fine
that's my game dude when I come up to a
girl I'm like hey it's tiny
that's true because then it fakes hey
nothing gets a girl wetter to do it
[Music]
what do you mean that's pretty average
is it
what is this character
Hey listen if I got married anybody else
can stay here come on guys please
Growers baby am I right I remember
um I actually had a serious conversation
about this with a guy that believed he
truly believed that um Asian men were
actually viewed as more unattractive
right they they believe that and then I
was like well that just didn't exist be
amongst me and my friends my world or
whatever he goes well it's easy for you
to say you have Charisma you have this
you have YouTube you're you're like in a
public eye whatever it is very easy for
you and I'm like
I mean but that has nothing to do with
race that's just success because and
it's also been like not even before
YouTube yeah you know I know because you
remember before YouTube I had a [ __ ]
up piece of [ __ ] car that was broken
down and it was costing like it was 400
still crushing one of the side mirrors
were melting it was melted
bro wait how is it melted it smells like
a champion
well because I had a car that burned
down in my garage and in my second car
kind of melted in the fire oh my God it
was covered in smoke it was a white car
and we called it cookies and cream paint
they're nice when it was a piece of [ __ ]
right with no clear coat because it got
melted off I don't know but I still had
dates and I mean because it's am I out I
just thought like yo
yo poor women that would think I'm rich
that's the right mentality today I
thought auction was genius
there's a voiceover than you you know
what I mean like I thought my dick was
short but there's always a vaginal Canal
that's a little shorty
this table's on fire
bad jokes crazy right now and it's not
his car
trying to find the brokest women there's
something for everybody but when he said
all those critias I was just like
oh you know what this is It's a
confidence issue and then you're just
making up like deficiencies so like
instead of finding someone that you want
to have a genuine relationship with you
you already see yourself so low that you
don't feel worthy of someone's love
that's why the victim mentality is the
problem yeah so they blame and go oh
they don't like me because I'm not
worthy enough and it's easier to just
hear that and go oh that's why yeah
like all these women don't know what's
good for them I'm a nice guy I hate oh
those are the worst people you're an
insult you think that women owe you
their affection because you're nice you
are definitely not a nice person you're
the exact you're a manipulator hey stop
talking [ __ ] on my game dog
yeah it works though it's like oh my God
all my pick-up lines are not working
I'm right here do my pickup line too
it's so slow
[Laughter]
I bet you can't tell the difference
between my pubic hair and my penis oh
really [ __ ] I got too real
you lose it all the time too huh okay
we're doing ass the feels now
yeah oh man I don't know [ __ ] those guys
[ __ ] chat I just want to say that I
really really hate him
I would like to take a moment on this
show to say [ __ ] those guys
sometimes no no you know what I got dude
stop talking about King just like that I
think what I'm hoping is is
someone out there is listening and then
if you had those thoughts before just
know that it might not be it really
might not be a race issue don't blame
the race maybe it has something to do
with your [ __ ] face
what it is you are worthy
thank you
foreign